a pressure injury or ulcer is a wound
caused by constant pressure on your skin
it may also be called a pressure sore
pressure ulcer bedsore or decubitus
ulcer
pressure injuries occur most frequently
in areas where your bones are close to
the skin including your heels ankles
hips tailbone
or elbows
in order to understand how pressure
injuries happen it's important to know
about the layers of the skin
your skin is made up of three main
layers the top layer called the
epidermis is a thin layer that protects
your body from the environment
the thicker middle layer is called the
dermis its main functions are to supply
the epidermis with nutrients help
regulate your body temperature and
provide strength and elasticity to your
skin
the innermost layer is called the
hypodermis or subcutaneous layer this
layer stores fat which cushions the
muscles and Bones beneath it
in a pressure injury constant pressure
on the skin over a long period of time
can compress the blood vessels that
supply the layers with the oxygen and
nutrients they need to survive
if there's not enough blood flow your
skin tissue begins to die and a pressure
injury forms
if you have a pressure injury your
health care provider will classify it
based on what can be known about the
depth of tissue damage
this is called staging
in a stage one pressure injury the skin
is intact red and inflamed the redness
is non-blanchable this means it doesn't
become pale if you press on it
a stage 2 pressure injury appears as a
blister or an open sore there is partial
thickness loss of the epidermis and
dermis
the areas surrounding the sore may be
red and irritated
a stage 3 pressure injury is a Crater
Lake full thickness loss of skin it
extends down to the fat tissue of the
hypodermis
stage four is the most severe a stage 4
pressure injury is a full thickness loss
of tissue
it extends through all three layers of
skin and into the underlying muscle or
bone
an unstageable pressure injury is a full
thickness loss of tissue
it's called unstageable because the
injury is covered by dead tissue making
it hard to tell how deep it is
and a suspected deep tissue injury
appears as a marooned or purple area of
the skin
it may contain a blister filled with
blood
it looks like this because of damaged
soft tissue underneath your skin
to prevent infection in your pressure
injury your doctor will clean your wound
using water and a mild soap or saline
solution
if your wound is severe your doctor will
debride or surgically remove the dead
tissue from the pressure injury
to protect your wound and keep it from
drying out while it heals your doctor
May cover it with a specialized bandage
to find out more about pressure injuries
talk to your health care provider